you might use the word abstract when
someone's making ambiguous statements or
to refer to groups of things you lump
together or to talk about things you
can't pin down to a single object in
space and time research papers have
abstracts art can be abstract and we can
engage in abstract thinking but what is
it about something that makes it
abstract give me a pattern here's one
orange basketball wheel what's the
pattern here well when you compare them
side by side you get this idea of round
just by focusing on this shape we can
abstract this shape from these three
objects in the world around us of course
if you're more of a top-down guy like
Plato was I get that you start with the
idea of round and you can go out and
find instances of round things wheels
balls and oranges it was comparing
things in our world that made us stop
and think about the abstract concept
around that kind of comparison is a huge
step one that gets us humans were really
far but that's not quite enough let's
look a little closer at the steps we
took to get to that abstract notion
round I mean looking at this object
alone we could have easily ended up
abstracting wheel or spokes or tyre or
something else when we place it next to
the other objects we compare them to see
their common features but that's still
not enough think about it we have a list
of specific features each object has and
one of them on each list happens to be
shared but if we take away the details
of each object we get to the abstraction
in the 1960s two norwegian computer
scientists recognized the technological
power of abstraction
they introduced classes which allowed
programmers to define abstract concepts
like say a sphere and objects which let
programmers create specific instances of
that class like a golf ball or a globe
they used abstraction to give birth to
object-oriented programming and there
are many more examples of the
technological power of abstractions but
abstract thinking isn't just the stuff
of new technology it's something we do
every day with language and thought even
though say every cat is different we can
have just a word for the abstract cat
same for person we can set up conceptual
hierarchies we can even abstract numbers
away to a simple variable that can take
on any value we need it to this kind of
thing is extremely convenient what's
even better is that if we just go one
step further abstractions become even
more powerful and we'll take that step
next time
you